nell'agone chi più ha più dà
di più
ok ma sto gioco per caso in 4k perché si
vede che non c'è neanche lo spazio nella
bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo monolite che sono famiglie e oggi
siamo su un gioco pixellosi ssimo però
devo fare delle cose deve uscire di qua
e winscape ha corso anche se lo storage
di oggetti mo bene questo cambia colore
va bene allora dobbiamo trovare tutte le
cose da fare qua c'è un punto è un
enigma a ai quad e può aprire la porta
va bene la porta è chiusa con mille
lucchetti con lucchetti dei match va
bene c'è ma come ha fatto spegnere 15 no
prima a sinistra si fosse spenta la luce
l'ho sentito con passano ragazzi sta
impazzendo
adesso siete due rumori orribili ma dove
non ho capito questo ho fatto la mia
sparito il teschio che avevo preso ed è
finito
ma allora non sono pazzo io
ma il quadro è diventato cosa succede
che krypi santo iddio che è successo
fazzoletto per pulire o fazzoletto
questo non lo so ragazzi stanno
succedendo cose aiutatemi non capisco
cosa devo fare
uguale
eppure c'è un manga ria dov'è il tele
non lo vedo neanche dov'è il telefono
ecco pronto
no niente pensato di rispondere ma non
si capisce niente le cose qui puntini
checa kimi significa cosa vuol dire ha
forse forse capito i colori dove
tricolore giusto aspetta questo è
marrone qui marrone questo qua no perché
ogni tanto si spengono le luci qual è il
problema già non si capisce una sega
questo e il marrone ok perfetto va
bene
mentre gli altri sono sono passi di
fiori va bene
a era un frammento di specchio
bellissimo che ho capito era un
frammento di specchio e quindi devo
trovare i frammenti nello di questo
specchio qua va bene
che cosa ho fatto
ho attivato qualcosa va bè ragazzi e
pieno di roba non si capisce nulla
allora abbiamo
quello da 2 così
ok 2 lug
beh devo mettere il bruco la donna
grazia il blu è qua il 2 e marrone è
sentita però fatica stroia questo è
rosso
ne mancano ancora le manca ancora
fatto
cos'ha fatto cosa facendo a sono le
chiavi quelle ma la vangol
trovate due tie ferma che già è un
miracolo e società allora si sono
bloccati tutti si sono bloccati in un di
qui dice l'ho fatta ma non ho capito a
fare cosa ce l'ho fatta ma non ho capito
cosa ho fatto ah ecco qua c'era una ok
già bloccato il cassetto adesso gioca la
blue me ne manca una me ne manca una che
è ovviamente qua dentro però non so con
che criterio sbloccare questa dei colori
ok i colori non sto telefona basta
che palle poi non ho capito se non
faccio qualcosa per un po di tempo forse
muoio tipo fai da te freddy's però non
ne sono sicurissimo non so la sequenza
di colori quale dovrebbe essere non ne
ho idea lo dici tu sia noi dice addio
peccato
no st lucio de merda o che succede lì
stanno impazzendo sta impazzendo la casa
forse è meglio che mi muova prima che io
muoia un film che maniera sicuramente
succederà
ebbene
non lo so la se non la so non ne ho idea
non ho la minima idea a zero cioè non so
come
partendo la quadra rosso marrone
blu e verde può essere quello giusto
telefono che fastidio 6 ore le telefono
allora allora date sino al 4 il
marroncino 2 milioni si capisce niente
spezia nero non si capisce
l'uno e blu
uno blu quindi uno blu 2 nero 4
palloncino manca quello in mezzo
cinema con il mezzo che può essere
qualsiasi
madonna che anzi allegati
o ce l'ho fatta era questo il verde
questo era verde 3 manaccia tema due ore
e mezza sommesso va bene
ed è anzi si spostato va bene che faccio
io adesso ho trovato a questo è un
pirullo non era chi allora lo so che
l'ha sia ragazzi potrebbe essere
qualsiasi cosa non è la chiave ottimo
potrebbe essere qualsiasi roba che
cacchio ne so io dovevo ficcare solo
prova bene e l'ha messo un carillon
vabbè era semplice no e ci volevo
zio ai visione bravo che sonorizzato
fare adesso
sono andata la zia
è una bella canzone mi fa piacere però
mi servirebbe una chiave servirebbe una
chiave poi loro
[Musica]
reggae nostrano sono questa era bello
complimenti si è spaccato qualcosa ho
sentito
se scassato questo ho trovato cos'è
stato un accendino
l'unica volta che si è capito che cosa
era un oggetto l'unica l'unica l'unica
capito niente fino ad ora ma va bene ho
acceso il camino e quindi
a molto easy 99 fuga dei tre esempi di
scondito io voglio solo uscire let's go
libertà a punto interrogativo col
telefono che squilla tra l'altro è
successo così mi è finito il gioco va
bene mi sei anche interrotta la
registrazione fa tutto lui può montare
sul video non so iori questa era project
h progetto h molto carino come concept
di gioco non ho capito un cazzo quello
che ho fatto ma bello bello bello
proprio ordine nato proprio soddisfatto
soddisfa shaun quello che vi sia
piaciuto anche se un po contino forse
oggi ma comunque meritava come gioco
molto carino e noi ci vediamo come
sempre domani col proseguito bello
ragazzi
[Musica]